bonjour alexis je trouvais comme chaque
lundi maintenant dans la matinale de rtl
france alors la réunion est attendue ce
soir entre le premier ministre le
ministre de l'intérieur et les syndicats
de police est ce que c'est une réunion
d'urgence
oui on peut parler d'une réunion
d'urgence je crois que dans certains des
sujets que vous venez de montrer on voit
bien qu'il ya une cocotte-minute qui a
ras-le-bol réelle au sein des équipes de
police il ya eu l'attentât islamiste de
rambouillet où stéphanie m'enfermer a
perdu habile et puis éric masson à
avignon abattu froidement par un dealer
d'une vingtaine d'années qui aurait été
peut-être arrêté dans la nuit en deux
hommes en fuite vers l'espagne ont été
arrêtées après les nombreuses recherches
on a vu les cérémonies ce week end 1
pour éric masson sur les champs-elysées
mais avignon des milliers de personnes
pas seulement des policiers toute la
population derrière sa police qui se
rend compte que ce métier est dangereux
il le manque de moyens est toujours des
violences tout le week-end à lyon à
fréjus et ailleurs où les policiers sont
pris pour cible lors d'interventions où
ils sont sur des terrains d'opérations
qui sont dignes de la guerre civile on a
un vrai problème en france c'est les
trafics un trafic de drogue les trafics
d'armes également qui circulent avec des
caches d'armes dans de nombreux
quartiers et je crois que au delà des
commémorations qui sont nécessaires la
police attend maintenant autre chose une
réponse politique une réponse dans la
loi et c'est en cela que la réunion de
ce soir est extrêmement importante parce
qu'en plus tous les syndicats de manière
unitaire les syndicats de police ont
appelé d'abord à une sorte de boycott à
suspendre la participation beauvau de la
sécurité et puis aussi à cette marche
citoyenne du 19 mai où ils seront
rejoints je pense par une grande partie
de la population oui c'est une marche
citoyenne effectivement où la population
a été appelée
est ce qu'il y aura une incompréhension
entre l'exécutif et la police nationale
selon vous oui je crois que le en même
temps des malades mac on ne peut pas
fonctionner en matière de sécurité c'est
là où il ya toute la compréhension d'un
côté un discours du président qui dit
oui la violence augmente
et puis ils dénoncent également les
violences policières et puis il ne donne
pas les moyens et de l'autre côté un
ministre
de la justice montré du doigt à eric
dupond-moretti parce que la justice
aussi manque de moyens mais elle paraît
laxiste face aux policiers qui eux font
leur travail d'arrêter les délinquants
qui les voit relâcher ou peut condamner
le voilà maintenant ce ministre en
campagne dans les hautes france alors
qu'ils devraient à 100% occupé à sa
mission qui est d'être le garde des
sceaux donc il ya une vraie
incompréhension des mesures aussi qui
font état de mesurettes par les deux
caméras de sécurité il y en a déjà
beaucoup des caméras alors apparemment
pas assez 10 millions pour assurer la
sécurité des commissariats mais 10
millions celles enveloppe dépensés par
le gouvernement pour payer les conseils
de mckinsey et des cabinets de conseil
et consorts dans cette crise sanitaire
c'est une broutille en réalité compte
tenu des besoins de la police et puis il
ya toute cette loi de sécurité globale
qui au lieu de donner des moyens à la
police est bien fait monter les polices
privées pour la sécurisation des espaces
publics que ce soit au tour des
commerces ou ailleurs et qui va compter
sur les agents municipaux pour pallier
les manques finalement de la police
nationale donc on est loin finalement
d'un plan national d aide à la police
et c'est en ça je pense que ceux de
cette réunion de ce soir va sans doute
de débloquer des choses ou moins mettre
la pression sur l'exécutif dans cette
gestion sécuritaire travail et une
grande consultation en ce moment
justement entre l'exécutif le ministère
de l'intérieur et les policiers pourra
redorer notamment l'image d'un des
policiers
c'est le bobo de la sécurité est ce
qu'il est mort né mais je crois que le
bobo de la sécurité comme toutes ces
grands rendez-vous qu'on a eue de sigur
de la santé etc sont d'abord des des
moments de communication politique pour
les ministres pour le gouvernement mais
qui n'engage à rien et c'est en cela que
tous les syndicats de manière unitaire
de police ont dit on c'est pas la peine
de participer à cette mise en scène du
pouvoir
on ne va rien en retirer donc là
clairement on voit bien que si si il ya
un bobo de la sécurité il devra sortir
des lois une changement de doctrine
peut-être on a vu un syndicat
france police alors certes minoritaire
mais qui appelle à un changement de
doctrine notamment sur le droit de
riposte des policiers avec le danger
bien sûr d'aller vers davantage de
violence on a vu les dégâts que ça peut
faire par exemple au brésil avec cette
intervention meurtrière de la police à
rio mais on voit bien que les policiers
ont besoin de gages à la fois sur les
moyens qui peuvent avoir de se défendre
les moyens alloués pour la défense des
commissariats mais aussi les moyens
qu'ils ont tout simplement pour faire
leur travail
et puis je crois qu'il ya aussi un
changement de mentalité au sein de la
police depuis nicolas sarkozy on a mis
en place cette idée du new public
management comme quoi tous les services
publics devaient être manager comme des
entreprises et la police était en fer de
lance de cette réforme de l'état et la
culture du chiffre et est au coeur de
cette réforme l'idée c'est que il faut
faire du chiffre pour montrer qu'on est
efficace ce qui peut parfois conduire à
des comportements idiot ou inutiles et
la police c'est pas du chiffre c'est un
travail sur la protection des
populations sur l'humain et en
l'occurrence je crois qu'il va falloir
revoir complètement la façon dont son
manager c'est commissariat alors manager
c'est un gros mot à dire qu'on peut dire
mais sont gérées ces commissariats
ce service public mal aimé des français
on l'a vu depuis les manifestations des
gilet jaune est essentiel dans la
société donc il y a un gros travail à
faire pour pour que la police puisse
enfin faire son travail dans des bonnes
conditions
merci beaucoup alexis pour votre édito
ce matin sur les violences contre les
policiers
la réunion ce soir justement des
syndicats de police avec le matignon
avec le premier ministre merci beaucoup